is the best feeling in the world and I
don't want to end
Alexis's smile lights up the room when
do you realize that you started having
feelings for this one I don't really
have specifics I mean we literally we
rehearse 24/7 so will you become best
friends with your partner I think that's
like at this harder or easier in the
ballroom knowing that there is this
chemistry you know I honestly I think
it's we're more open with each other and
we trust each other a little bit more in
we can just have fun and not have to
worry about hurting each other's
feelings I guess I don't know so to be
honest I think the transparency is what
makes it easier it's so much fun to
dance with someone that you have a
connection with it's almost like time
slows down we communicate not just
through our steps and our movements but
with our hearts too
I am developing feelings for Alan and
I didn't see this one coming will you
pull questions out of our trick-or-treat
retreat
show us your cheesiest corporated in the
country I'm gonna choose another one can
root can you reveal one really sweet
thing you love about your partner oh she
comes in here and gives me massages
every day like she's a hey Alan and Mary
Lou and Sasha Alexis and Alan on this
sixth week of competition the couple
leaving right now
is Mary Lou and Sasha all right guys
in the bottom two again what are we
gonna do with you I mean maybe people
can start voting for us that would be
really nice well you know we're having
so much fun out then honestly it's such
a damper on the night we're in the
bottom but you know we're safe and
that's all that matters we get another
week and we get another chance to dance
for America Alan he's awesome he's super
outgoing
he's definitely been a really good
reflection for me to not take myself
those years